hey baby I'm your baby ah you sound a
lot different ten minutes ago so happy
I'm back in my house with my wife hey
Bubba with them a lot with them away hey
Dad
alright let's go see how the missus is
doing all right dad I'll come with you
dad
boom badoom boom boom oh don't blame me
for servicing your wife better than you
ever could well you don't know that
what are you talking I've been attacking
my own house yeah oh my god hey sweetie
oh honey yeah good
what are you did you see them you
distract them oh I already have
[ __ ] I'm gonna get you hot no
you're not how good this happened he's
out the back dad okay over here dad
where creepy little dog piss out of my
barks okay why do I hear you [ __ ]
where'd you go what do I do with this I
mean the green office - I won't get
white aah oh my god [ __ ] so much taser
you have all the Tasers alright then 12
meters wait where I'm like it'll be
better if I close the bar that doesn't
tell me anything
Wow oh that's good honey I mean I can
operate doors that's [ __ ] awesome
under that dog good bit longer pit I
don't have you [ __ ]
where the [ __ ] you I hear he's on the
balcony upstairs sir running in circles
sir thank you her calling makeup I don't
that's their father Sir way to shoot him
don't shoot mom what wait we're
happening I'm missing out you know you
yeah baby
you got quiet up stop stop
were stopped oh I'm a cop I'm allowed to
do hey stop beating the [ __ ] out of Wade
yeah that's right I just drank some
water though I'm just drinking out of
the hell is going on no I ain't Bowl
fine oh we're fighting the wrong well
deck so forget you where you stopped
running I don't know where the past
where I've got my ass beat so bad
yeah I've been terrible - for the hate
what is this music so loud well maybe go
ahead I'm punching you why they're not
doing I'm sorry you're right I don't
intend to
sir are you [ __ ] her upstairs
alright I am upstairs I don't know how
to go upstairs they've got your last
article on living here if you know Hey
okay I punched my wife ten times in the
failure rate the [ __ ] I couldn't do one
second in your house and [ __ ] your wife
and leaves on flinch I can't deal with
this I can't do anything besides get my
ass beat
it was the [ __ ] spannabis I want Eve
again apparently oh wait am I to love
her now okay all right then no I know I
thought that was wait okay you want to
be the lover more I'm gonna sneak you
want to love her you can be the lover
yeah I'd like to I'd like to do that how
do I not be the lover now I don't never
go go go for it oh yeah there you go
haha
all right honey so I'm gonna supposed to
find some clothes and stuff I think so
yeah you need to find offense and I sure
then you can go out the front door it
must be I find it for you and help you
again II think so baby
hey hit V man you know solve it man
you're still hot baby thanks babe
oh god yeah I love it oh yeah by yeah
yeah eat your ass hang on here we go
I'm on the bed I think how do I dream
I'm on the bed I can't there there we go
hang on wait wait yeah baby oh yeah B
baby on the bed is so hot oh yeah let me
do this
but wait oh yeah oh oh my god man what
the hell restart that [ __ ] immediately
I was punching the [ __ ] out of you I
where did you get a Taser there in the
safe
what do staves have you played this
before
hello you know what's really hot and all
but I'm [ __ ] out of here all right
get out in fact I should probably run do
I don't feel safe here
wifey you're not allowed help of knowing
helping you know wiping up what are you
trying to shoot me hey did you just try
to shoot you [ __ ] up good this will only
give you some opened doors open door
open door am I supposed to help you oh I
see if I look at something I highlight
it I think is that I better be nice if I
could open doors to get over there you
can how you're a dog do it now we lay
our trap
OOP there's only one place I can go
boy oh yeah I don't want to clean up my
marriage
all right wait wait wait wait hold side
down cut hair no sleep and my wife with
it no well you don't know yeah there was
no sleeping so I got it you know me
Oh didn't oh don't do it no looking back
me punch me punch me I swear on my face
where am I Fido broke the map ah yeah
come here
why are you so broken it's really no
problem oh you're a dynamic commander I
don't like this uh I'm like right behind
I know I'm afraid to even look because I
know you're so [ __ ] annoying huh
uh-huh
oh why are you come back when the front
gate no please huh [ __ ] you know
we know you gotta go gotta go gotta go
no oh [ __ ] town oh I just pissed all
over the game it's really hard to hit
the lover but Jack's good maybe we
should just sit down and have a nice
counseling session instead mediated by a
dog I agree with that yeah that sounds
like something civil something enjoyable
maybe for all all parties oh yeah babe
babe I don't know how you eat babe this
is the [ __ ] I've always wanted
we dare to come over tomorrow my wife
this is manna this has been a real
physical connection but I don't think
we're connecting emotionally I feel like
you're resolving your unhappy marriage
with flings with other people as a way
of projecting your own inner pain on
others so I feel like the only way to
rectify this problem is to have a long
discussion with your husband so then
yeah you get you feel me you give me
mm-hmm
okay so let's just talk with them no
okay I'm out of here
I peed there's an apple wait come back
lover oh there's an [ __ ] for you here
over here over here we're looking Oh get
the Apple my lover no you want in here
too my lover my light oh you get a
banana too lover I got anything Bob I
mean my lover mark my lover
oh where the hell is everyone are there
there's a doughnut oh thank you Bob
thank you there's a my love are your
lover it can help you it's adorable that
is cute lover my lover
okay all right Lana banana there's a
banana here my lover lover lover lover
hey I found a donut why did you miss in
this doorway oh I slipped in the bamboo
oh my god you slip it falls
yeah if you there's that is hilarious oh
wait what does it do this they must be
over here man yeah Wow hey sorry
[ __ ] dog I miss oh my god this guy
coop space in his house I thought we
were here to talk no I got like a nice a
nice recording desk set up in here this
is pretty super dog doo doo doo doo doo
doo oh here I go now that actually had a
mood you get a photo
Frank you yeah [ __ ] how do I go down hey
I found an apple for you love her
thank you I've got plenty oh you get
your Panther over five I got my pan oh
cool
I don't know this to me wait over here
boy you missed help house yeah oh you
put a TV down
where are us over what's happening what
oh yeah right ah what happened - there's
all this [ __ ] ball - ball yup you
slipped on a banana peel garlic are you
gonna do they know we're dead we're
downstairs we're done I guess right go
after a task - no it's pretty fun uh
yeah I'm working out this is the new
ways Jazzercise I'm saying
yeah let's do subscribe oh oh [ __ ] in
I guess I'm gonna go sorry if you got a
years old I could leave school I get it
they're your new games hosted all right
doing all the playing for
[Music]